bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement ou j'accueille
juliette ferry dany bientôt possiblement
docteur en physique c'est pas là c'est
vrai que ça ses productions la très
probablement avec quoi était quasiment
égal à voilà voilà mitsou donc je vais
te s'intéressant en particulier à la
philosophie de ce meeting bonjour
juliette ou bonjour des soldats aux
mathématiques la thèse écrite
oui madame manon donc j'ai tu es ce que
tu peux nous parler un petit peu de ton
parcours
alors mon parcours il est assez
classique
j'ai commencé par une hypokhâgne khâgne
littéraire donc les prépas littéraires
mais là j'ai pu ça s'était plutôt par
nahd mais c'était vraiment trop de
travail d'après pas donc je suis parti à
la fraq ensuite j'ai une m3 de philo et
puis ensuite un master de philo mais en
master de philosophie des sciences et
j'ai fait rare sur une année d'erasmus
entre temps qu'il nous offir manque de
terre puis ensuite j'ai enchaîné sur la
tête
la thèse de philosophie aux médecins et
ça les fait qu'on s'y arrête donc c'est
un vent enregistrement en fait d'une
première interview ce procès ne ratez
pas très bon et donc à la fois tu
m'avais parlé pas mal de ce passage en
angleterre comme un passage important en
fait dans ton web en fait donc la
philosophie en prépa c'est un point un
peu comme la philosophie en terminale
donc c'est certain il ya des nations au
programme puis après on travaille sur
plein d'auteurs et on fait des
dissertation de philosophie qui sait à
peu près tout
c'est ce qu'ont fait donc on dit
beaucoup de textes d'histoire de la
pilot
mais c'est surtout pour pourra ensuite à
écrire des dissertations et déjà le
grand changement c'est une fois que
j'arrive à l'université que c'était
beaucoup plus poussé tout d'etam raconte
c'est beaucoup plus but c'était pas
simplement de faire une certes l'arrêt
partiel sous n'y avait pas forcément
disserte et j'ai aussi découvert la
philosophie des sciences j'ai lu en
cours mieux comme on dit de philosophie
de la biologie sur la théorie de
l'évolution que j'ai adoré et puis j'ai
eu aussi mon cours sur la fiction et
comment la fiction est un thème de
réflexion métaphysique épistémologique
sur le langage excellent parce que
c'était passionnant du coup j'ai
découverte ça et j'ai réalisé que à mes
enfants je comprend enfin d'autres
choses aussi
est-ce que même si j'étais en option
pilot en prépa que j'avais pris soeur à
l'option concours et devoirs en fait
j'étais pas forcément encore très sûr de
moi
voilà je n'étais pas un génie de la
philo quoi bon ensuite moqué
je me disais que je gêne coordination et
donc c'est aussi pour ça que j'ai voulu
étudier la philosophie
en fait je sais plus pourquoi j'ai voulu
aller mais sinon c'était un match choc
puisque là on s'est surtout de la
philosophie analytique d'accuser
finition ce aussi encore et aussi je
suis parti en minceur là bas les élèves
de master en angleterre ils sont un peu
traités comme des doctorants donc on
était 10ème avec les docteurs ont
compris qu'on allait au séminaire de
recherche une écrivaine déminer mémoire
il y avait pas partiel
c'était une façon de faire de la philo
beaucoup plus épanouissante pour moi que
la prépa ou même juste les parties
docta part et de la philosophie la
biologie qu'est ce que c'est qu'est-ce
qu'ils étudient en philosophie de
théologie
c'était un cours 101 philosophe qui
s'appelle thomas pradeau chiemsee
secours c'est un cours d'introduction à
la théorie de l'évolution et du coup on
lisait darwin et l'origine des espèces
et donc qu'ils accueillent tout un pont
à ses fins un gros de la vulgarisation
de la théorie de l'évolution est assez
sérieuse quoi et ensuite on est vraiment
allé regarder des textes des gens qui
ont participé à ce qu'on appelle la
santé la synthèse moderne de l'évolution
donc on a étudié un peu la façon dont la
théorie des motions s'est imposé en tant
que théorie scientifique dans le champ
d'à biologie et on étudie aussi du coût
des philosophes de la biologie qui ont
écrit sur sept thèmes même des
biologistes parfois par exemple on dit
l'article de démentis et 2 gold sur les
unités de sélectionner on réfléchit là
dessus qu'est ce qu'une unité de
sélection ce genre de choses est en
crise depuis la biologie a plein de
réflexions
c'est vraiment un champ très très bien
organisé donc il ya des questions comme
qu'est ce qu'une fonction biologique et
quel rapport avec l'évolution
qu'est ce qu'un individu de sexe ont un
niveau de section g diaby est ce que la
biologie à des lois par exemple
qu'est-ce que le concept d'espèce il ya
plein de réflexions entre dans ce genre
de cas ce qu il a un petit côté histoire
pardon est aussi un côté histoire
biologique
on a fait beaucoup de l'histoire d'un
come en latin comment darwin est arrivée
à sète hérault d'évolution par exemple
tous les débats ok c'est un peu de tout
mélanger et donc sur la partie fonction
ça rejoint un peu le fonctionnalisme
alors en fait en théorie de l'évolution
enfin la biologie le problème c'est de
définir ce qui est une fonction
biologique par exemple comprendre s'agit
de comprendre de la phrase
cette phrase par exemple qui est la
fonction du coeur et de pomper le sang
qu'est ce que ça veut dire un peu
théorique et là il ya plusieurs types d
approches qui sont donc c'est assez
différentes des chansons les montagnes à
plusieurs types d' approche qui
s'affrontent y en a qui défendent une
approche théologique donc l'âme soeur de
finalisme cndd et que la fonction du cas
c'est l'effet sélectionnés en but
dans le but de faire ce que fait le
coeur quand les deux c'est qu'il faut
pouvoir distinguer entre la véritable
fonction du coeur ne fait que les là
pour compter le sang et des et des
choses qui ont été sélectionnés par
l'évolution ou pas sélectionné par
l'émotion parce que c'était juste un
effet secondaire de la fonction première
par exemple le bruit que le coeur tu
fais quand il bat c'est pas la fonction
du coeur proprement dit
même si même si c'est ce qui fait aussi
bref il ya donc à beaucoup de débats est
ce que on doit définir la fonction ce
qui a été sélectionné pour arbitrer 6 et
puis il ya d'autres philosophes qui
argumentent contre cette position et qui
défendent que la fonction de quelque
chose la fonction d'un organe de logique
ou de n'importe quoi biologique
c'est juste ce qu'elle fait donc c'est
non plus qu on appelle cette position
mais en gros c'est plus en rapport avec
qu'est-ce que par le bloc le coeur
qu'est ce qui fait qu'elles sont ken et
son appart causal dans un système et
donc c'est ça sa fonction mais du coup
se pose le problème du mais du coup à ce
que le coeur en fête qui bat le bruit
que sa fille parce que du coup comme ça
paie
ça te fait partie du système est ce que
c'est une fonction et ça paraît logique
là dessus mais bon c'est pas juste de
m'interroger sur des choses que j'ai
notamment
il faudra donc si vous voulez on mettra
des biens dans la description de la
vidéo avec des articles que vous pouvez
dire si c'est une astuce de vidéastes ça
c'est white 1973 et que les dates que je
ne sois pas des villes hôtes partie jeu
très intéressante que deux tu parais cc
d'utilisation l'analyse de la fiction la
relation entre la fiction et la
philosophie c'est alors ça ça peut
demander à thibault vinçon grosse
secours et d'un gros c'était ça son prix
autour de la problématique suivante qui
et comment on fait pour énoncer des
vérités à propos d' objets qui n'existe
pas uniquement des entités fictionnel de
type gandalf sherlock holmes les
exemples qui reviennent et donc chargé
de td emile coué mais il me faut jamais
donner comme sujet de dm gang gandalf
partie lembach ben est donc l'objet d'un
choix que j'avais pas une trop bonne
en tout cas l'objet c'était de
s'expliquer que lui comparez vous à
cette question il fallait pouvoir avant
tout une théorie philosophique qui on
n'est pas ça totalement incohérent est
ce que en général d'été sont liées au
fait que nos propositions sont en accord
avec l'état du nil si on se réfère du
cours quelque chose qui n'est pas dans
le monde
ça donne plein de choses bizarres et du
coup il ya plein de choses qui rentrent
philosophe david luiz qui me propose que
du coup on
interroge encore surtout que j'aime bien
quand gros des choses sont vraies dans
des mondes possibles
donc ça c'est cela sa solution pour doit
très vite il ya un autre philosophe
partis bourgeois parce qu'il a un peu
trop sur sa décision tombe pas qui dit
qu'il ya des objets qui n'existe pas et
comme il ya des objets ça permet de dire
deux choses en même temps il n'existe
pas sa thèse c'est sûr ça il a dans un
petit de synthèse ouais c'est ça ça
paraît dingue et remind mes valeurs et
c'est mépriser moi dans mon cours c'est
pas trop et estivaux il parle beaucoup
du rencard est un objet qui n'existe pas
qui en plus est auto contradictoires on
a beaucoup parlé de ça et il avait aussi
une autre problématique un peu plus
facile à saisir
c'est donc on le dit un roman on y par
exemple anna karénine comment ça se fait
qu'on peut ressentir des émotions
sachant que l'émotion passée rationné à
propos de personnage qui n'existe pas
comment ce fait comment se laisse
prendre par ce rebond pense pas à
pleurer car la direction de nous sommes
très forte
pas tout le monde loin de cash et du
coup on peut donner quoi ça se passe
comme ça il ya des lentilles kanak
législation donc ça c'est son intrigue
qui t'ont fait dire que la philosophie
c'est trop bien bah disons qu'avec le
fait que j'avais plus ou moins à mon
souvenir sacem ici ça veut dire que ça
va marquer toutes ces choses là bah
ouais c'était beaucoup plus intéressant
ça paraît de lamballe c'était plus
intéressant que beaucoup d'autres choses
comme 0 concours de pilotes a fait son
taff et tendance la distinction entre la
philosophie analytique et philosophie
que je pense
dit explicitement mais ce que tu peux
paroisse alors cette distinction
j'essaie de la contrainte du coup de
pied un peu j'ai découvert ces nouveaux
courts en essence puis ensuite en master
vraiment le choc c'est quand je
discutais avec mes camarades de classe
en erasmus ou même juste avec les profs
dont c'était vraiment un gouffre quoi on
parlait pas bien même chose et on
parlait tout était dit du coup l'une des
explications ça serait à bahia ce
gouffre entre pieuse aussi content il
est allé chez nous et filles à meetic
mais en fait cette distinction elle
recouvre pas du tout
pas vraiment en fait la réalité la
philosophie continentale qui ressemble
beaucoup à la tude aux automatique
la philosophie analytique philosophique
en dessous du coup c'est totalement
absurde ce que je lis pas ce que ça
suppose que je distingue des deux war
dire ça mais bon mais en gros il ya
plein de clichés de deux types de
philosophie qui demeure comme quoi par
exemple quand ça c'est plutôt du côté
d'un muscle c'est absurde
du coup il ya des gens qui pensent
qu'ils sont plutôt côté philosophe
analytique et qui sont plus rigoureux et
plus logique et plus rationnelle que la
philosophie mais plutôt dans la lignée
de la science
et eux ils pensent que la cocue mantel
en talent c'est plus proche de la poésie
ou hawks est moins rigoureux ou que
c'est pas clair etc
mais en fait il ya plein de fusils
automatiques qui n'est pas du tout clair
donc c'est un bon argument il ya plein
de philosophes qui sont pas continentaux
qui pense pas du tout là qu'une fille
est une science du projet la science
quan aux points bas coûts comme les
écouteurs et continentaux perçoivent
souhaitait parler de la manière dont
épisode je pense qu'il ya un mépris des
deux côtés je sais pas exactement six
ans je pense qu'ils s'en fichent des
philosophes des rythmiques ou alors ils
pensent qu'ils sont arrogants jeunes
inventent parce que du coup je pas
vraiment
concentré je pense qu'ils sont un peu
arrogant et qui voit pas les qui sont un
peu simpliste qui va pas les vrais
problèmes de la question c'est ce que
les continentaux dirait des analytiques
dit ouais enfin après juste pas trop me
demander mes jambes sont qui dirait un
peu genre de choses qui sont ignorants
mais ça c'est peut-être vrai par exemple
ça me remettra paix quand il était allé
en stage là alors oui ça fait penser à
la cnil c'est un peu comme quand je ne
sais pas non comme cette news me
regardez là on n'a pas du tout ça c'est
ça c'est peut-être plus devra donc il ya
longtemps que j'ai pas mal de russes qui
est que les faits sauf continentaux
s'intéresse beaucoup plus à l'histoire
de philosophie n'ont en fait pas
vraiment pas tant que ça ainsi plus dans
la formation partante
du coup c'est ce que j'avais expliqué
leur façon différente de l'approché
philosophique mais peut-être aussi
thématiques etc
il ya aussi une différence de poids en
terme de groupe social dans la façon
dont les philosophes travail
comment ils ont été éduqués intrigue la
fac est juste leurs habitudes de travail
et leur façon de faire quoi tu te fais
tu peux donner un exemple de d'un truc
que tu as dit et du coup les les les
gens en angleterre tu regardes avec des
gros yeux à je ne sais pas trop à un
monde jeune et j'ai voulu parler d'eux
un homme en fait c'est plutôt l'inversé
plus d qui il parlait d'un philosophe
continentale mais genre très très
vaguement ah oui c'est comme heidegger
vallée me regarder et une pointe il dit
en rigolant à djeddah le coup
honnêtement j'ai choisi le rider
beaucoup de surprises aussi
mais on voit les images fantasmée de ce
que la philosophie contre continental et
empêche par exemple merci beaucoup mais
ils vont pas forcément avoir les mêmes
références
les mêmes odeurs je pense qu'il est j'ai
par exemple j'ai eu tout un cours si aux
etats-unis cette année chaînes aux états
unis pendant ma thèse j'ai postulé en
cours sur le transcendantalisme chez
kant mais chez tous les autres arrêtent
fois c'était super décaissement et d'un
autre côté c'était pas comme en france
au sens en france on va faire ni sort
d'un fils oh le coup sûr dans le par
exemple va vraiment un c'est un peu de
l'histoire qu'on essaie de voir ce
qu'ils ont pensé et on essaye pas
forcément enfin si c'est pas cohérent ce
pas cohérent mais cette juste de voir ce
qu'ils ont vraiment du cas c'est ce que
je dois comprendre confie qu il met dans
un dîner dans ce court c'était plus on
essaye de faire nouvelle théorie nous
inciter pas s'était jamais très clair on
fait ce qu'ils essaient de faire n'était
pas simplement une histoire et c'est de
comprendre ce commentaire en bleu dire
qu'on essaie de construire une théorie à
partir de ce que c'est ça c'était ça en
tout cas je n'ai pas bien à distinguer
les deux bons jeux se suivent il est
compliqué et met en lutte en angleterre
on a aussi eu des coups voilà on il
avait paragraphe par paragraphe on
essaye de comprendre donc c'est donc à
la conclusion qu'il ya vraiment une
vraie distinction est peut-être que la
distinction ce communiqué disait elle
est surtout peut-être sociologique la
langue utilisée plutôt de l'anglais pour
l'accusé depuis deux mois une éthique ou
la philosophie des sciences et le
langage utilisé qui est plutôt plus
incisif plus court pareil avec des
phrases plus courtes way est un langage
plus pas pompé mais genre plus élégant
plus recherchés jeudi midi libre et en
philosophie et donc pendant ton
mass-start a fait un mémoire
parce qu'on ferme et pointent en tête le
masters du coup en erasmus quand je suis
parti j'ai fait un master
parce que là bas c'est que en face à
l'apathie ambiante france et j'ai fait
moi-même 2 donc en pôle fixe à fait
comme dom est mon premier noir j'ai fait
de la philosophie de médecine parce que
je voulais faire la file dhabi originaux
personne de compétent sur le sujet en
termes de processeurs en w c'est un peu
par défaut je suis revenu en france je
suis j'ai fait ça chew geste et de la
théorie gpda a plus d'esprit netiq et
puis j'ai réalisé que c'était un peu
chiant enfin que c'était drôle parce
qu'on pouvait argumenter contre
argumenter pour tir dans le détail mais
on pouvait pas moi réfléchir à des
problèmes qui remporta la société parce
qu'il peut donner l'exemple
ce que tu as étudié à tuer dans l'oeuf
d'esprit j'ai du coup j'ai étudié le
concept
le concept de douleur mais du coup du
point de vue de la commande publique
alors voilà ce thème c'était à mon chine
pouvait pas expliquer en go en la
théorie majorité dominante ans qui vous
étiez d'esprit contemporaine c'est de
dire que mon nom vous êtes à mon tour
présentés c'est ça qui est des
caractéristiques qui les caractérise et
du coup c'est le cas du coup on se
demande du coup la douleur c'est un état
mental
et qu'est ce qu'elle représente dans le
monde c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'elles
ont de quoi aider diriger et du coup il
ya un débat là-dessus parce que certains
ont pu le disque du coup la douleur
représente un dommage corporel et
d'autres disent que si on dit ça alors
on oublie de caractère des ados
caractère désagréable de la douleur est
en fait c'est ce débat là qui a eu droit
à un exposé technique qui présuppose
quand même que la date et au point toute
la théorie représentation liste
noir déjà grondé toute cette théorie
après je voyais mon cas de la douleur et
je sais pas pourquoi en fait c'est
vraiment étrange ya tout un débat qui
s'est fait faillir beaucoup beaucoup
d'auteurs donc d'être et mangeant
bretons se répondent tous assurent sur
ce sujet très très très très pointue
très petit quoi et à la fin mon mémoire
manger c'est de montrer que la
philosophie la médecine avait peut-être
des choses à dire sur ces questions
puisqu'il ya un autre il ya un débat en
cause la médecine sur les concepts de
santé de maladie et sur le concept de
dysfonction dans le cadre de la sainte
et d'amadou et le fait que c'est assez
difficile de définir le concept de
dommages corporels ou de dysfonction de
maladie d'un point de vue purement
naturaliste du coup je montrais que
parent dans un champ il ya un consensus
c'est ça et pourquoi ces sages expliqué
et du coup je disais bon bah c'est pas
étonnant que dire que la douleur
représente un dommage corporel
ça va être compliqué d'un point de vue
purement prince va être compliqué dans
band hero naturel ses parents se montrer
novateur en commun et du coup je lis est
déjà dans la philosophie damati du coup
tu as fait ta thèse en philosophie
magazine latina se fit la matinée mais
en même temps je sais pas trop si
j'étais la philosophie des sciences est
un peu bizarre parce que je me suis
intéressé ajustement des approches
anglophone n'est pas du tout en un pays
où les approches un groupe funky et
s'inspire de philosophes continentaux
pour développer toutes sortes de
théories sur la médecine et notamment
l'idée que la philosophie permettra
d'humaniser la médecine philosophie du
coup d approche un peu continental
du coup ma thèse est vraiment entre les
de quoi est faite la relieur parlerons
entre deux chaises et donc dans ta thèse
que ce que tu défends
dans ma terrasse du coup j'ai défend
l'idée que pas un problème en fait
penser s'approche mais ironiquement
séparément des problèmes intrinsèques
pour moi les plus gros problème ce n'est
plus gros coincé que elles sont pas
annonce fidèles tout reproche aux
inspirations contre mon talent qu'elles
prennent du coup j'utilise mon on pas
utiliser mes connaissances
pas forcément très l'importance d'une
méconnaissance ou nationaux fixant
talent pour montrer que ces approches
anglophone s'appuie de vraiment trop
loin et parfois véritable contresens sur
ce qu'est par exemple technologie ou la
narrativité par exemple et du coup ça
sera un premier problème et c'est ce que
j'étudie dans un premier temps et
ensuite du monde que leur critique de la
science et du naturalisme donc ces deux
choses quel cadeau qu'elle met beaucoup
en avant que ses critiques là sont pas
très convaincante et à la fin j'ai dit
qu'en gros ben s'ils défendent
d'humanisme en médecine c'est cette
approche la barre ne pas le défendre et
donc c'est ça que j'aime ma thèse contre
l'humanisme en maîtrisant tomtit j'ai
pas appeler comme ça une critique de
l'humanisme
je sais que tu utilises qu'il entend se
retourner de partout sur twitter non
mais bon voilà après je pense qu'il ya
d'autres façon de défendre mon sens
d'humanisme
c'est ce que je fais à la fin de ma
thèse non c'est pas pareil de
phénoménologie et c'est à dire ah tiens
à dire une super expérience que la peine
nommé nologie criminologie bah c'est un
peu ambigu parce que du coup c'est non
point dans le contexte français et
francophones nous annoncer ça va pas
référence à la à des approches des
approches philosophiques phénoménologie
traditionnel quoi ça va être la
philosophie développée par soeur
lightoller tout ça
qui sont pas bref qu'il développe
justement des thèses sur
l'intentionnalité que je tarn et ce dont
je parlais tout à l'heure le fait que
notre esprit représente le monde donc on
voit que ce défi contrainte à contrôler
sa part parfois des même chose quand
même
donc ça c'est ça et puis en fait des
farc phénoménologie phénoménologie
surtout qu'on taxe en guinée des fois ça
fait juste référence à l'effet que nous
fait une expérience
du coup comme tel à l'effet que cela
fait d'avoir une douleur c'est qu'elle
est désagréable ou douloureuses
ce genre de choses est bon et du coup il
ya cette ambiguïté le terme n'est pas
forcément utilisés pour les mêmes choses
et dans le corpus que j'étudie bain du
coude qui sont des gens qui défendent
sorte de phénoménologie de la médecine
fenomeno maladie en fait la définition
en gros qui retiennent jeux nature et je
résume très rapidement mais en gros ils
retiennent l'idée que la phénoménologie
c'est d'études des expériences
subjectives donc de tout effet que cela
fait d'avoir cette expérience est en
fait dû en fait c'est assez réducteur
par rapport au projet phénoménologique
bien sûr de mon sort et doit être de
garde notamment parce que c'était des
projets traités métaphysique rentrée des
questions métaphysiques transcendantale
je vais pas trop dans l'esprit saint
georges épistémologique ce n'était pas
juste on va décrire des expériences
subjectives parce qu'ici avait déjà très
bien à l'époque la psychologie c'est ça
ou que d'autres séances peu d art comme
par exemple la littérature persane
du coup bas et je pense que j'ai donc la
phénoménologie donne beaucoup
d'importance du coup à l'aspect
subjectif si j'ai bien compris
pour ressentir oui ah bah du coup on
sent mieux
en fait je sais encore un peu toujours
de comprendre ça parce que je pas fait
de mal
on sent que les approches que j'étudie
elle se concentre trop sur les
expériences subjectives
donc ton expérience à toi dès mon
expérience amour à juliette
alors qu'en fait la phénologie
traditionnel s'intéresser à la
subjectivité avec un grand m et c'était
plus des questions du type le mois le
sujet est la condition de possibilité de
d'expérience et du monde précédé des
questions un peu comme ça
transcendantale sur les conditions de
possibilité de de ce qu'on peut
connaître et c'est une pareille
nietzsche heidegger c'était carrément la
question de l'être donc aucune
métaphysique tumeur et heidegger à la
zambie
c'est à ce jeu que vous devez retenir
sur le guen sait qu'au début de lettres
et on dit qu'on pouvoir avoir une
réflexion sur l'être avec un a majuscule
il faut passer par la seule façon c'est
de passer par les temps fin c'est à dire
les humains dans l apostrophe non les et
manquera les étincelles et non de type 2
est enfin l etat zain au mal du coup il
avait vraiment un rapport à la
subjectivité mais ce n'était pas un gène
est qui va au parc c'était pas ça kraft
est bon et je pense que il ya des
phénomènes contemporains qui dirait que
il ya d'autres façons de faire de la
pédagogie qui s'intéressent
effectivement une expérience subjective
comme le font sont des gens que j'étudie
mais comme les gens que j'étudie il
parle pas de ces gens là ils parlent
juste à l'égard de sa basse à pezens
problème un peu de cohérence pour leur
approche et les hommes qui sont pas très
bien compris ou alors il dit du trot en
fait les approches dont il s'inspire
pour défendre l'art organismes alors
qu'en fait c'est pas forcément
les plus aisés où les approches les plus
évidentes pour défendre cette approche
donc si j'essaie de résumer dis moi si
je me trompe
il ya des parties de fil des meetings
qui essayait de réinterpréter était donc
la phénoménologie en moi je pense qu'ils
ont leur interprète mal en faisant de
l'individu et de l'expérience
individuelle le coeur de l'essaim de ce
qui est intéressant
souhaitant en médecine ouais c'est ça
que tu critiques dans ta thèse ouais du
coup il ya deux aspects à la fois les
problèmes mais tapie toufik ou
métaphysique et complément des gangs au
pineau de problème qui est bon qu'est ce
que c'est d'humanisme en médecine est ce
que c'est vraiment important et donc toi
tu penses que c'est en fin de thèse dit
que l'humanisme en tout cas vu comme
l'étude de chacun de façon individuelle
est quelque chose de pas souhaitable en
médecine a pas souhaitable il sait pas
mais ce que je finis d'écrire cette
partie en gros qu'est ce que j'écris en
gros je parle déjà j'ai une thèse qui
est que qui est que si de ma naissance
et l'empathie c'est à dire le fait de
ressentir des mois sur l'autre
c'est pas souhaitable mais si
effectivement donc pour le coach ou
contre cette sorte d'humanisme
empathique ensuite yann l'ancienne place
pour quelque chose doute comme la
compassion qui est juste le fait de se
sentir de vouloir le bien de l'autre
mais ça je pense que c'est un peu
triviale et en même temps ça a été
tellement étudiées par un éthiques
dabio tic et tous ceux qui s'intéressent
à la médecine donc a pas besoin de faire
intervenir d'autres approches
philosophiques pour défendre sa pareille
je pense que ça sera je pense pas que
c'est une bonne idée d'en scène et donc
c'est tu dis donc pas comme jeddah
médecine mais une autre approche que la
médecine est relative non pas du tout
que ce soit du coup une bonne idée de
les sanctionner par exemple en fac de
médecine
ça serait beaucoup plus utile de se
concentrer par exemple sur
des enseignements des tic pour en gros à
l'éthique c'est ça permettrait de leur
donner des réponses des armes des choses
des réflexions pour savoir ce qu'il faut
pas faire d'un point de vue éthique
alors que c'est pas forcément le cas
et ensuite du montre qu il ya un autre
aspect que si nous approchons pas vu on
regarde pas de façon assez étrange c'est
des systèmes de santé et je me dis que
peut-être la goutte question importante
à poser sur l'humanisme donc ça va plus
être des questions de encore des
questions éthiques mais des questions
sur la justice et d'accès aux soins
donc si on fait le meilleur médecin
humains empathique etc
si on met dans un système qui de toute
façon n'est pas accessible parce que par
exemple ne sont pas remboursés en fait
c'est magnifique c'est pas un brin
humanisme même pas accès aux médecins et
c'est pas anodin parce que du coup il ya
certains de ses défenseurs qui sont
américains et que je comprends pas trop
pourquoi les défenseurs m'approche
rendent pas compte du côté paradoxal de
la poche
tu peux expliquer un peu ce qu'est la
matinée relatives à alors la médecine
ratings
c'est de cette partie actuellement c'est
surtout une médecin qui a fait une thèse
de littérature mais qui est médecin
résine qui défend cette approche c'est
l'idée que la technique narratologie qui
est technique de critique littéraire
donc ça c'est beau cours de français au
collège
savoir identifier qui est le narrateur
le contexte d'évolution et tous est là
elle pense que certain charme elle pense
que
c'est utile pour le médecin pour tout un
tas de choses mais en réalité ce que je
disais donc en plein plein plein de
problèmes avec cette approche mais au
début de ma partie je précise quand même
que ça s'est inspiré ça a donné lieu à
plein d'autres choses qui sont pas
vraiment de la médecine narrative au
sens strict du terme qui sont par
exemple juste l'analyse littéraire de
récits de maladie donc ça c'est pas de
la philosophie la théologie c'est juste
des gens qui étudient trois mois en fac
de lettres elle est réussie de malades
est ce qu'on peut dire et c'est quand je
critique la médecine ratifie je critique
pas ces récits douala leur analyse
critique juste des thèses ramon très
forte sur la médecine le lien entre la
médecine et la critique qui était un peu
exagérée par les défenseurs laminé
narrative qui ont surtout repose sur une
critique de la science qui n'est pas
satisfaisante dirais quoi typiquement
les gens qui défendent de médecine est
relative bas en plus ce qu'ils disent ce
qu'ils disent qu'ils font des x est un
peu paradoxal mais qu'ils vont dire bah
je vais écouter en fait ça va ça va être
il va avoir des grands slogans sur la
narration mais en fait dans les faits
ils vont juste dire d'un je vais écouter
le récit de mon fils de passion de son
expérience
je vais l'aider à donner un sens à ce
manga si je vais peut-être découvrir des
choses dans ce récit ou alors je vais
revenir chez moi je vais réfléchir aux
récits que c'est une passion et du coup
je vais penser autrement et je vais
découvrir en fait ce qui l'a
véritablement derrière souvent il y aura
une sorte de petit clairement une
inspiration psychanalytique sur ces
questions angoissées par le langage
qu'on va guérir certains troubles qui en
fait ne sont pas biologique c'est la
défenseure principal a co écrit des
choses sont faites assez explicite
et donc tu parles de slogans dame est
inégal radio c'est juste le fait qu'on
parle déjà de médecine est relatif c'est
un peu étrange que ça existait vraiment
extra après y'a vraiment des formations
en fac de médecine aux états unis même
en france qu'il donne ce genre de
formations souvent ça ça compte ça va
surtout au stade on va faire dire des
élèves aux élèves des récits de la bible
pour l'heure maintenant parce que c'est
une sarah cadre à voir avec les
ambitions épistémologique de la médecine
nativement telles qu'elles sont souvent
si je convaincs la folle à la
phénoménologie et la médecine narrative
essaie de mettre en avant cette relation
aux individus et à travers notamment le
l'empathie et de contrôle en pâtit ce
que tu veux ouais développer un résultat
c'est un des points communs entre les
deux approches un point commun qui est
étonnant parce que quand on regarde la
narratologie l'empathie et c'est pas du
tout hein c'est pas quelque chose qui
bat qui m'a très bien avec la
narratologie c'est plus un problème
c'est un peu ce que je faisais pas un
point de la fiction d'empathie pour la
phénoménologie c'est encore pire parce
qu'au début c'est encore un problème d'
empathie pour eux que ce qui nous
parlait de la subjectivité l'accès aux
mines du coup il y avait l'accès à
autrui c'est encore plus compliqué et
d'empathie savait rien à voir avec les
émissions c'était plus la question
comment je connais d'esprit de l'autre
une sorte d'empathie qu'on m'appellerait
cognitives donc dire est ce un peu
étonnant que ces deux approches
reviennent à l'empathie dans étonnants
d'un point d'une méta si on veut dire et
en même temps c'est pas étonnant parce
que du coup d'humanisme qu'elle défende
cette sorte d'humanisme qui font des
sauts et donc pourquoi je suis contre
contre l'empathie c'est un livre de
psychologues poil doux c'est aussi un
article du philosophe aux cheveux bleus
c'est que sinon encore la chemise de 6
pi 6 po
ouais il a peut-être qui la suit ja de
l'aveyron la machine commune en gros
c'est la mi chemin entre la philosophie
éthique la philosophie philosophie
morale et la psychologie des gens qui
défendent l'idée que l'empathie en
général necdet finit effectivement comme
l'empathie mon style c'est à dire le
fait de ressentir des émotions de
l'autre se mettre à sa place n'est pas
quelque chose qui va mener aux
meilleures actions possibles
donc c'est sous ce genre de réflexions
souvent menées dans un cadre plutôt
conséquentialiste et utilitariste donc
il ya pas mal d'expérience qui montrent
que si on oublie que l'empathie dont se
sentent ses émotions
c'est un sujet il aura tendance à ne pas
choisir non pas prendre la décision la
plus juste possible et donc même parfois
à discriminer clairement de personnes tu
peux te donner un exemple de telle
expérience
oui en gros l'expérience qui me vient
c'est un rapport avec la médecine c'est
pas lui qui donne ça mais je pense aussi
mise en bouche comment l'expérience de
psycho est fait mais en gros contrat des
gens soit on dit juste à quelqu'un voilà
sept enfants elle a beaucoup besoin
d'une greffe est ce qu'on la mine dans
dans la liste de gens qui tuent attendre
pour une vague sachant que cette liste
allait parfaitement calculé on part du
principe qu'elle est juste là monde
c'est à dire est ce qu ont du coup
quelqu'un perde discriminer les pendus
est ce que quelqu'un va perdre de la
chance et à d'autres on leur dit à bien
regarder cet enfant lors d'une deuxième
a changé c'est plus que mon conseil
c'est mais on essaye de produire
sentiment d'empathie où l'on explique
plein de choses pour qu'on soit restée
petit pour l'enfant est là d'une bien
sûr c'est que les gens à qui on a chez
qui on apprenait plus empathique fait le
plus souvent en fait n'était 700 points
dans la liste est donc en fait la bonne
décision qui est pas juste pour les
autres enfants qui s'affrontent celle
tout aussi mignon et trieste et c est
donc en gros tout ça ça peut être résumé
en disant que ben ont pâti en fait elle
va fonctionner comme un du chipset intel
fardeau comme un faisceau lumineux qui
est clair certains problèmes des gens
plus pro gym où notre famille nous a mis
notre cas social notre apparence
appartenance culturelle excédent ou même
juste pas là en france et pas à l'autre
bout lui parce que c'est loin du coup il
va pas avoir va pas forcément prendre de
meilleures décisions
mais ça je sais que tu sais pas ce que
tu arrêtes pas de partager des choses
sur l'altruisme cheater clairement par
exemple quelqu'un qui va être partisan
de la truite inefficace
on va aussi être content pâti en tout
cas faire gaffe un peu parce que c'est
pas facile a priori si on sait qu'il ya
une liste de personnes qui ont besoin de
greffe et elle il ya le père de l'enfant
qui vient nous voir en train de pleurer
lui dire bon enfant ils exigeaient de
cette liste et neuf premiers à priori si
l'on était bien gérée à une raison qui
soit devant mais ça serait ça c'est
difficile de pas vouloir l'aider au mot
et bah oui mais apparemment ça se pose
aussi dans la charité ben on a envie de
donner dans on va donner par impulsion
par une donnée papa impulsion en
quelqu'un camions sont excusés c'était
pas grave
et en fait parce que ça va être
totalement inutiles nous avons au
contraire en cause des problèmes que tu
as parlé par exemple ça va partager le
site de give one fait que que par
exemple juste financer des filets anti
moustiques ça va être plus efficace
juste à apporter un cadeau l'enfant qui
me rend malade alors que du coup bah
voilà mais tout ça pour dire que en
france je sais pas trop mais par exemple
aux états unis l'empathie c'est vraiment
regardé comme mieux critères noir et par
extension tous les discours d'obama ou
plein tous les politiques d'une part et
d'empathie
comme si ça allait résoudre tout en fait
alors que peut-être tant d'un point de
vue strictement morale si on peut
commencer comme ça tu le dis à la fac du
coup il y avait des études ou des gens
qui essayait de promouvoir des jeunes
l'enseignement de l'empathie pour les
médecins à oui on met lâchant 3 demander
si j'ai vraiment le temps d'écrire cette
partie les en gros il ya un truc qui m'a
intéressé c'est que il ya un argument
qui revient souvent chez les médecins et
chez les gens qui étudient dans
m'intéresse c'est que les étudiants et
des étudiantes en médecine à la fin de
leurs études elles sont moins empathique
qu'au début de leur métier c'est dit et
en fait quand on regarde les études on
cherche ce type de littérature tient au
point un plan d'études dans ses chambres
à mi cuisson des gens qui essaient de
montrer ça genre des centaines et des
centaines d'études du coup j'étais
curieuse autant d'études sur ce sujet ça
doit être vrai alors même qu'on est en
fait quand on regarde bien c'est
intéressant de voir les introductions de
ces études qui font parfois souvent
référence soit directement aux approches
que je sois juste à ce courant un peu
débile ou d'humanisme médicale
donc on voit que c'est un peu circulaire
parce que si des arguments de
l'innovation médicale c'est que les
étudiants sont moins empathique et que
les études qui produisent ces études là
sont elle même basée sur des arguments
ministre mais c'est aussi que quand on
regarde en fait dans le détail ce que
des études ce que c'était une mesure
souvent en fait c'est pas du tout clair
puisque donc comme on lui faisait il ya
plusieurs sens du mot empathie marsan
strict on patine nationale s'y mettre à
la place de lattre
le sens un peu traditionnelle de la
phénologie senghor par exemple n'en
pâtit comme une tique le sens de
comprendre d'esprit 200 que démissions
interviennent juste la compassion le
fait de se soucier
c'est un peu vague je ne prends pas trop
sais pas je ne compte pas forcément de
trop cette mission fait de se soucier du
bien-être
d'autres pièces il ya aussi la contagion
émotionnelle qui est assez explicite et
voilà et en fait quand on regarde bien
c'est souvent que des questionnaires
déjà toutes les études donc souvent les
gens ils vont réponses qu'on attendait
d'eux en fait il ne puisse répondre car
disons que je les respecte mais là on va
pouvoir conclure que c'est ce que les
étudiants pensent qu'il faut répondre en
gros j'ai donc fait un tube donc c'est
déjà un problème et ensuite dans les
critères de définition de l'empathie du
coup sont totalement vois ça change en
fait part par suivant les études des
fois ça change pendant l'étude des fois
y'a pas de définition du tout du coup
c'est un peu le bazar est donc un
message passion que j'aurai le temps de
bien croiser ce sujet du coup ça me
semble en fait une tête assez bientôt
les mêmes d'un point de vue empirique
qui m'agrée fait que des centaines
d'études
si finalement cette étude à son que sur
des questionnaires et qu en plus à
mesure des choses différentes
concrètement qu'est ce qui te semble
douteuse c'est que les étudiants en
médecine soit plus que soit moins
empathique à la fin de leurs études au
sens de l'empathie
bah du coup ce packard parce que ça
dépend du sens nous donne à l'empathie
maison pour l'instant je t'ai pas que si
elle est fausse mais je bats célébrer
cette thèse on dirait qu'elle a un peu
de vous tous en tout cas en terme d'
empathie émotionnel
hier c'est presque même souhaitable
potentiellement en tout cas que
l'empathie émotionnel diminue au fur et
à mesure des études
j'imagine parce que sinon du recours
parce qu'ils sont en contact avec
beaucoup de souffrance
donc on dit que ça serait plutôt
souhaitable qu'ils qu'il est moins
d'empathie
tu veux dire souhaitable pour eux ou
pour les pressions à bab aux coureurs
déjà parce que c'est fatigant mais
j'imagine aussi pour les patients
donc s'il ya d'autres façons de traiter
mentation que de ressentir ce qui
ressemble très patient il paniqué
paniquer ou mémé même c'est un cas qui
est discutée par le partizan de
l'empathie mais elle avait cette passion
qui voulait mourir absolument elle avait
tellement d'empathie pour aig a beaucoup
qui même en tête des fois sans une chose
que auquel on pense pas mais éprouver de
l'empathie c'est pas dans des fois on va
pas y arriver
surtout si la personne très différente
de nous une très malade très bien
du coup s'il faut que vous fonder sur ma
tempe a teenage pas en aucune empathie
ce qui paraît normal ne va pas forcément
pour tous pour notre passion pas se
retrouver démunis je pense puisqu'il
apprend que c'est ça l'important dans la
cantine du disque en faveur de ne plus
voir d'enseigner le fait que l'empathie
émotionnel n'est pas forcément
souhaitable et qui
oui bah disons que je sais pas si je
dirais qu'il faut l'enseigner déjà si on
peut arrêter de bourrer le crâne avec
l'empathie musulmans mais le seul
problème c'est que c'est andy qui en
fait le terme
du coup peut-être qu'ils entendent juste
d'être qu'il faut se soucier du bien
d'autrui et en même temps il ya aussi
donc je faisais tout c'est tout les
types qui doutent des lois tout ça et ça
pour enseigner ce à quoi les tic est
plus fondamental que cette notion
d'empathie tout cas pour juger plus plus
loin du coup car enfin partir un peu
plus d'un an den heureusement un peu
plus qui fait un peu en arrière et qui
pose un peu plus des réflexions
critiques avant d'en venir à bout c'est
vrai que ça fait moins slogan sap témoin
on est blindé lyon en plus je pense que
ça c'est vraiment un truc à moi pas
rentrer là dedans mais juste
c'est très émouvant la façon dont
l'éthique médicale des titans médecine
fait en france
et donc est la façon dont elle est reçue
aussi dans le médecin qui n'ont pas
forcément d'ivoire qu'on leur parle
d'éthique
tu penses que les tic en médecine du mal
en france bah moi un roulage pas
spécialiste de tic
même si sa parenthèse mais enseignement
traite de ça et est-ce que je rencontre
dans ce que vont dire des médecins sur
les tic aux commandants des étudiants ce
que ce que je vais voir dans les mains
cadeaux d'études de médecine
c'est un peu bizarre quand je ne veux
pas d'un très bon oeil gauche c'est un
peu bizarre
enfin juste pour dire un exemple ça
arrive à montrer régulièrement que
toutes ces formations des tic
c'est dans ces mots nautiques soit pas
du tout donné par deux jours par des
philosophes en fait je pense qu'en fait
il ya aussi une autre confusion
sémantique avec la déontologie le fait
de respecter les règles déontologiques
qui sont celles du code de déontologie
des médecins sauf que du coup c'est dans
un autre sens c'est pas juste respecter
les règles c'est qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
qu'est ce qui ne va pas c'est vrai faire
un pas en arrière désir que réfléchir un
truc plus fondamental que les règles qui
ont été fixées gle bas on peut aussi
réussir en règle le problème d'ailleurs
je pense qu'ils ont été faites
certainement clairement en rapport avec
détection d'un manteau de tic tac ya pas
juste assez docteur en éthique wild
propre trouve qu'ils peuvent pour
l'enseigné juste pas du coup tu pense
qu'il ya assez de réflexion critique
vous est ce que tu penses que les le
problème c'est plus que les réflexions
éthiques sont mal fondées ou bah du coup
là je donne ma langue au chat parce que
je pense qu'il faudrait une sainte
d'études empiriques pour voir qu'est ce
qui est enseigné bras
dans toutes les facs bon à quel niveau
genre est ce que c'est des lieux
d'études vont toujours tenir
l'information de ses patrons nous aussi
on est censé avoir des formations de
type en doctorat je ne veux pas qu'on
pense que c'est en fait je me suis
encore un mail de l'école doctorale
aujourd'hui du coup bah il faudrait
juste en sorte d'état des lieux sur ceci
n'est que ne sait pas quoi faire
intel là dessus c'est bizarre c'est
quand même utile aussi donc non je près
de dix ans est ce que c'est vraiment une
question pire et pour le coup et kate a
l'impression par rapport à l'image de la
philosophie que se font les médecins je
pense que je sais pas je pense qu'il ya
des médecins qui adore justement parce
que ça leur permet de défendre cette
approche ce soir d'humanisme médicale et
puis on a qui aiment pas parce qu'il
donne garde un peu et qui trouve ça
totalement sion je pense qu'une grosse
partie de la philosophie de jeu par des
amis c'est chez emi en temps je pensais
plutôt positif en france
je sais pas il faudrait aussi qu'on
sonne à profit ces questions et plus
globalement en dehors de la sphère des
médias ce qu'ils pensent de l'image de
cheseaux filles dans les médias en
france la philosophie centré soit sur
bac de philo soit sur les 128
d'intellectuels médiatiques slash
philosophe et du coup à une très bonne
image pensent les gens adorent enfin je
sais que n'importe quelle conférence de
philosophie qu un peu continental va
vraiment avoir une foule
on parie sur tout et dans les médias
c'est une philosophe là on leur donne
beaucoup d'importance et que c est moi
c'était ça pas question j'ai pas besoin
de l'as monaco
tu veux pas d'oublier c'est sa voix
c'est un peu parfois on se demande un
peu pourquoi on leur donne autant
d'importance alors quel point notre
chercheur qui travaille sur l'éducation
qui serait peut-être une place c'est
quoi et qu'est ce que tu penses qu'ils
pourraient être faits pour essayer de
vous mettre en avant ce d'autres
philosophes au bac la question donnez
moi quand je fais des gazaouis parce que
je t'avais dit la d1 fois que je pensais
que ce que faisait beau c'était
vachement important est que sa chaîne
youtube de développer un peu de thé
beaucoup de philosophie ce le sujet de
terminale et de son film il introduit
aussi dans philosophie des sciences la
chose de physique contemporaine
d'autres trucs des trucs désigné comme
chez les autres d'esprit hors dom c'est
génial et en plus ça marche ça veut dire
que les gens ont vite ce à quoi tu
savais que j'ai même une épiphanie
du coup je me disais qu'il fallait faire
comme thibault mais en se concentrant
sur la chemise à carreaux parce qu'ils
n'ont pas assez que si nous en allons
voir une seule d'emploi bleus terminent
par exemple donc il faudrait carrément
chaîne youtube pour ça tu as passé de
diversité on pas dans la philosophie
comme avait fait en france les auteurs
classiques les pêcheurs à ce que je
connais une philosophe femme a pourtant
titre à bien regarder les vidéos de
thibaut petit a tant fait ce n'était pas
sur ses allées chris iannetta reste à
oui oui oui mais 10ème titre les faits
s'est vu comme un symbole
tu n'es pas à [ __ ] comme un pied des
pics et du cta quel point tu
t'intéresses à d'autres occasions
philosophie que physique à quel point
dans pas mal puisqu'en fait qu'une fine
art mintsa à ses transversales
je m'intéresse à des questions toujours
un peu la philosophie la biologie lors
même si je comprends approfondir ce
qu'ils ont fait des sciences aussi et
surtout le croisement entre philosophie
des sciences et l'étude des sciences
histoire sociologie descente ça super
intéressant quand les trois prochains
sont croisés et du coup en ce moment
bien cosmetics que les jo j'ai donné un
cours d'éthique d'introduction à
l'éthique comme ont gagné 4 6%
est ce que tu peux lui parler de cet
égard de gueule du coup ça parce que
demain c'est un philosophe de la
médecine genzyme qui a pu bien une qui
s'appelle médicaux ni les ondes donc on
irait ce médicament est en fait c'est
assez intéressant donc le livre n'est
pas parfait c'est intéressant parce que
il reprend beaucoup beaucoup d'exemples
donc parmi les pilotes qui fait qu'il y
avait meilleur à mandela problème avec
la façon noir la science médicale était
faite qu'il y avait beaucoup promis que
bing et une défend la thèse selon
laquelle surestime d'efficacité des
traitements pharmaceutiques ont
sous-estimé aussi en
là les effets indésirables qu'ils ont et
pour défendre cette thèse c'est un peu
étrange et s'appuie sur plein vent plein
d'exemples donc un petit côté inductif
tous ces exemples acquis ni que
s'étaient trompés ou crois donc qu'il y
avait de voir des affaires de zappadu et
un tantinet propose d'unifier son
argument dans son livre à partir dans ce
qui va pas d'arguments m il s'appuie sur
après je sais que d'une de mes collègues
et pas trop convaincu par sa donc
générer demain ce cas là bas et non mais
de toute façon il va donc te libre dans
l'appareil devrait être traduit en
français et nous recensions critique et
critique du livre la fois on est
peut-être aussi en pensée plus tard
quand mon temps et je pense qu'à
l'occasion
j'essaierai de faire un peu vulgaire
lâchant sur le sujet parce que je pense
que c'est vachement bien donc l'argument
de ces guignols pour dire que parce
qu'il s'est quand même tu as assez
surprenante pour le coup ah bah du coup
plein d'arguments mais c'est que je me
tiendrais c'est que les hongrois ont
pensé juste le biais de publications qui
font qu'on va publier plus tôt il va
avoir des intérêts financiers justes lié
à la structure de l'alliance qui sont
comme a publié des résultats positifs
donc il faut que le médicament marche
mais c'est nick monde qu'elle marche
sinon publiera pas la technique ou tout
type de d'études au stade en est
par recherche mais on va pas faire pour
les essais les études négatives donc à
ça et aussi donc ça va mener juste à se
concentrer sur de trop petit et donc oui
de médicaments il est il un bon effet
mais c'était la nuit
on avait un autre souci que le ceci qui
monte c'est que en fait la population
qu'on choisit c'est qu'il ya des travaux
chez moi la population de la population
la population qu'en choisissant les
essais en fait ça va être des gens qui
n'ont pas toujours de sens bien la
population la population
du coup pendant même un temps il y avait
des problèmes parce qu'on n'en conclut
pas assez de femmes mais ça peut être
juste le fait soit des personnes jeunes
en bonne santé etc ce point
et du coup les médicaments va être prêté
par l'as personnes jeunes en bonne santé
active ça va plutôt être prescrit à la
personne plutôt âgées les malades qui a
plein d'autres malades y en même temps
du coup c'est possible que dans ce cas
là on n'en sait rien ce n'était pas les
essais ça marche encore moins encore y
avoir des effets secondaires encore plus
graves tels donc ses deux deux idées la
kindle mais en fait il ya un point point
de plein de petits qui montrent qu'ils
sont pas forcément les batteurs par eux
mêmes
même si je crois qu'il a beaucoup publié
par les antidépresseurs particulièrement
l'huile d'argan qu'une fois qu'on les
absout sera rassemblée ensemble non ma
fille mon petit bassin pour conclure que
devrait avoir moins confiance dans les
traitements sais pas c'est pas tout la
médecine dont tu parles c'est vraiment
juste des traitements pharmaceutiques
qui y est là c'est la malléabilité des
études
ouais bah oui bah ça c'est un autre
sujet qui peinait
le fait que je me suis beaucoup je
connais pas vraiment qu'on peut
manipuler à ses passements montré qu'un
défi alors que d'autres exemples essayer
de répéter l'expérience en faisant des
petites modifications ajouts voilà ouais
voilà ça c'est fait oui oui bah oui il
parle de saulcy fin ils parlent plein de
trucs intéressants
moi je pense que m intéresse ici juste
pour être introduit à toutes les
réflexions qui m'ont été faites sur la
science de la production de la recherche
scientifique pas forcément quand même un
truc assez générales et il ya beaucoup
de riz sais pas ouais c'est pas parce
que c'est pas du coup une critique
vraiment ce que je sais que ça pourrait
être reçu comme ça par le grand public
ou d'autres chercheurs c'est pas une
petite caricaturale de la science peut
être pas d'accord activities et je
déconnecte qui pensent que certains
voudraient que cette caricature nation
c'est pas tous les médicaments sont
jetés c'est pas non plus à tous les
labos pharmaceutiques principal du
conspirationnisme c'est pas de
l'antiscience c'est plus subtil que ce à
quoi nous pousse un temps après le titre
et peut-être un peu peur ouais bah ouais
après c'est la dernière partie son
ouvrage le titre est ce que je progresse
le médical ouais ça semble hors jeu
destiné normalement en gros je crois que
tu as écrit exactement mais sans qu' il
faut donc il faut plus goûté ces muscles
ça après du coup dans ce n'est reparti
de son livre ça un peu bizarre parce
qu'il défend une approche mois prochain
non ce qu'il utilise le terme de
médecine douce mais en français en
anglais en disant oui mais je fais bien
sûr pas référence sont une alternative
beaucoup donc à londres ait pas
et en même temps il ne définit pas du
tout ce que ça veut dire médecines
douces en france j'arme sont que ça
pourrait être intéressant pour mater
aussi manger ce qu'ils défendent soir
d'humanisme médicale en aient dominé
nice - qu'est-ce que ça me dit les oui
mais c'est un sorte de la façon dont les
livres sont écrits en anglais si souvent
il faut en créer un clip là en titre
parents qui accroche donc oui à ce qu'il
était vraiment obligé d'écrire médical
me disant je sais pas ce que tu puisses
pour parler beaucoup de médicaments
puisque pacifiquement les vaccins
ballons qu'il a l'idée qu'il ya des des
médicaments notamment des vaccins
quand je pense qu'ils n'en parlent pas
par exemple les antibiotiques qui marche
très très bien et donc n'est pas du tout
une illustre par rapport à ce genre de
toutes les choses et en fait quand il ya
un tube et comment ça s'appelle le mamba
papier toilette tout de suite entre
comme ça on chip eu comme on appelait ça
le ntfs révélations comme ça qu'on peut
mesurer sur sur un monde sur 100 et ses
genres le nombre de personnes que tu
dois traiter avec un médicament pour que
les personnes qui en bénéficient et en
fait est juste en train de dire que dans
par attention parce qu'il ya plein plein
de médicaments
ce nombre était très élevé quoi donc
faut raisonner en jean mais est ce que
c'est bien le type de données de 1000
personnes s'est personnellement domicile
sachant qu'il va avoir des effets mais
après s'ils voient qu'il ya également il
faut donner à deux personnes pour que
les deux qui sans eau ni dans 100%
et c'est vrai que la méthode tests
statistiques utilisés très fréquemment
en sciences et en particulier pour les
caisses de médicaments et tests
cliniques
c'est une méthode qui va tester s'il
existe un effet plutôt que
la taille de l'effet me voilà c'est ça
oui mais on wye en débat aussi là dessus
parce que selon lui
ainsi là où cela en est plus
philosophique selon lui on peut pas
vraiment un défendre une efficacité
empirique pur il faut regarder au niveau
du concept de maladie est-ce que ça
soigne vraiment la maladie en question
moi j'ai pas forcément 2.2 par cet
argument mais c'est juste aussi ce que
tu dis ça parce qu'il ya un peu un effet
même s'il est avéré qu'il faut du coup
qu'il faut du coup utilisé un médicament
c'est ce que tu disais et du coup
quelles sont les principales critiques
du livre de ces guignols
tu deviens des critiques qu'on pourrait
faire de nos bassins
j'en ai des gens des prises -
sous-entendu quelques-uns bon je te
transmettrait c'est une recension finit
bientôt
bah moi en moins d'un an après les cris
ok donc l'écrivant d'une journée deux
jours deux jours l'ambition hockey
mineur s'était du coup du coup votre
votre critique sortira avant la
publication de ce casse argumente le
ballon mais après on ne va pas le
publier tout de suite on dit que oui je
pense que là on va avoir le gros
brouillon quoi il vaut mieux vous le
rendrai pas disponible ça se fait ça de
rendre les tricks disponibles genre sur
arxiv ça se fait politique je ne sais
pas trop ce n'est pas 3 je pense qu'on
doit attendre c'est bon c'est parce que
c'est des collègues lui même ancien je
me remets un peu alors laissons je sais
pas trop ce qu'est ce qu'on va l'envoyer
à la review attendait retourne en bas
mais ça se fait ça ou de cuir dehors de
droit
ouais je pense qu'après parce que
l'ombre des philosophes des sciences
ensemble de tendance à agir un peu comme
des scientifiques comme ça se fait en
suisse s'attend à ce fardeau est aussi
parfois les genoux de philosophie en
fait accepte en cours avec ça il ya même
une archive de chez 18 des sciences qui
est genre comme objectif d'arriver à la
partie mais pour la philosophie des
sciences
ça existe je suis patient d'après midi
mais pas après si tu veux des critiques
et nadja point qu'on était fait du
niveau mais nous avons notre il sera
disponible au tauriac et isis et
détacher ses yeux cette grande étude
vous devez dire ah oui vraiment pas chez
moi c'est que du coup tu parles c'est
pour ça qu'on pas de 4 ans et de l'âge
d'or
c'est au mali des athéistes c'est le
compte twitter de matin mais elle a
beaucoup d'abonnés pour un compte
twitter je voudrais civile j'ai passé
vraiment en fait c'est bizarre parce que
les gens ils suivent
tu étais juste mais il intéresse jamais
avec moi en fait
tweet je comprends votre ont valu cité
d'être plus luxueux suivi ce qui est dur
ouais aux 700 personnes voici à 5,5 qui
ont lu ma thèse en page minimum 300
pages
et ça c'est pas ce que je fais
philosophie dans tous les sens mais moi
ça me désole que les trains de se
plaindre sur twitter sans victoire
voilà c'est que c'est tout le temps et
dont tu te considères matin ce que
j'avais fait un début un peu en mode
c'est quoi ces gens qui ont des comptes
twitter de chat du coup je suivrai s'ils
ont des comptes twitter de chamoiseau si
la rencontre était en fait déjà les
ondes 3 devrait donc les pourquoi du
coup m'a peut-être tweets et au début
mais elle était vraiment horrible
faisait que dire je lettre qu'elle tire
au flanc
franchement qu'est ce que tu sais pas
qui c'est et ça me ratais jamais déjà
réalisé ça depuis longtemps
ça n'a encore plus fort c'est avec le
travail sur travail en fait fait qu'on
travaille trop le surmenage
c'est assez courant et parfois on fait
un peu valorisées dans le discours
c'était vraiment étrange et qu'il y
avait vraiment des risques planning déjà
pour la santé mentale déjà en fait à
subir ça et du coup ça que j'ai fait
quelques vidéos sur youtube mais celle
dont je suis plus fier notamment parce
qu'elle est drôle si cette vidéo
qu'utilise prend la barre way lady quand
je reprends une étude de psychologie
cadeau fait sur la santé mentale de
détente et j'étais en fait que c'est
vraiment un problème
elle est super chouette cette vidéo un
point devant la salle quand tu achètes
dans itunes soyons honnête j'ai en fait
c'était vraiment horrible parce que là
je crois que c'est juste et l'ofii l em
ou php eux c'est plus loin je sais
punitif mais basse montagne j'ai fait ça
pour rigoler qui et puis en fait j'ai
mis ça sur twitter je prends un petit
bol d'air et toi vous avez un doute
hélas trop bien ce qui est une blague
arrêtait pourquoi du cac pages ainsi
prise au jeu j'ai vu leur talent dans
une vidéo ses dires le début qu'on fait
si bien et l'ofii et la vidéo c'est avec
qui était this s'appelle là le seul vrai
vlog de thèse que tel parce que ça aussi
qui m'avait inspiré c'était les vagues
d'otages notamment celui par exemple
manning ça sert absurde de blocs de
thèses et des zooms et puis du coup
c'est vraiment très amusé que j'ai fait
ça et et en même temps je tombais sur
cet article sur la détresse mentale de
temps et je me suis cela peut être aussi
d'expliquer ça bon après c'est un peu
étrange
ça donne une vidéo totalement absurde
avec des blagues qu'une étude
scientifique donc bizarre mais en temps
j'aime beaucoup
super chouette l'une des questions qui
avait posé c'était que dirais tu as ton
mois du passé ah non pas cette fois ci
la question jamais dit quoi
10 ainsi il faut étudier en la
philosophie du kremlin de post hoc
non je n'ai pas grand chose à dire moi
du passé la philosophie du climat du
coup c'est un domaine qui ouais ouais
bah il ya un mois il ya plein de daf de
deux têtes de bronze au t2
parce que tu m'avais demandé quels sont
les gros problèmes actuels j'avais dit
oui du coup questions les questions des
philosophes du climat eh bien rien à
prendre
klein mais je n'aime pas trop je sais
juste que dans mon labo on collecte
travail sur consensus qui a en
climatologie sur la charte mathématiques
comment commencer quelle sorte de
consensus et commence à peine mais je
serai pas exactement mais il aurait
probablement aussi des questionnements
éthiques en est aussi de philosophie des
sciences et des types d'essences plein
de trucs intrigue crevier qui m'a un
petit guide média
enseigne en cours d'éthique des animaux
c'est ça wade non j'ai donné en fait
c'était dans une milieu des tic
d'introduction éthiques
j'ai donné une seconde a fait une séance
sur l'éthique animale avec les étudiants
pour les étudiants c'est super fun jeu
chez les mêmes vidéos de données ou
grasset et de thibault stephen et du cou
pour voir ce coupage et de lire pas mal
sur le sujet est ce qu'on en sait un peu
mais pas pour moi et c'est intéressant
je pense ça va devenir de plus en plus
important dans nos sociétés partie des
tic profession tant que discipline ça
devrait aussi progresser
du coup une question que je me pose à
cesser comment est-ce que tu places le
genre de la biodiversité versus la
souffrance animale dans quel sens est-ce
qu'il vaut mieux sauver la biodiversité
qui tu as ketchup est ce qui est de la
souffrance animale vision à l'état a tu
parles de la vidéo faut-il te tuer on
peut sereinement à bout je n'ai pas trop
j'ai pas trop trop d'avis je sais qu'il
ya des gens qui travaillent là dessus
donc j'ai pas trop trop d'habillage sais
pas trop je sais pas trop mais par
exemple un message qui peut être utile
de dire c'est que ce que je lui dis
souvent dans les tweets scientifique
parce que du coup une course était
d'éthique animal mais c'était plutôt
c'était une introduction pouvoir
comprendre le cadre d'expérimentations
dans la science c'est qu'en fait il ya
un truc qui intime d'arguments qui ne
marche pas j'ai pas trop le temps on a
détaillé mes angoisses et de dire que on
a besoin de faire etc cette
expérimentation sur l'allemagne pour
faire cette recherche scientifique
de la nécessité donc on fait qu'on doit
faire cette chose scientifique à eybens
du coup il fait on doit le faire moral
en fait cette question totalement
différente
on peut pas passer de l'un à l'autre il
ya plein de choses sans mettre ces
circulaires de dire j'ai besoin de faire
ça pour faire ça ça a justifié rien au
fait moralement je sais que ça un truc
un peu difficile à comprendre pour
certains scientifiques qui sont année
mais je peux pas faire ce que je fais
c'est pas ça si je peux passer avec ses
draps et en fait c'est c'est pas la
question
c'est juste faut distinguer de la
nécessité ou pas d'ailleurs parce que
c'est vraiment nécessaire dons consentis
mais si même si c'est le cas en fait ça
ne dit pas qu'on doit le faire voilà
donc c'est peut-être un peu ça aussi
pour bien d'ivoire est sur une autre
question que s'est posé neuf fois c'est
est ce que tu as déjà dialoguer avec des
avec des médecins humaniste ou des
défenseurs de médecine humaniste
mondiale oubliée dans quel contexte
est-ce que tu as eue il ya eu des viols
pas parler un peu des questions autour
de l'empathie ou autre
ouais bah oui la conférence sa mort
absolument oui après j'ai assez peu q
j'ai assez peu échangé avec les gens que
je critique directement dans la tête je
sais que l'une des françaises par
exemple de la phénoménologie de la
médecine à lui certaines cliniques que
j'ai pu lire et normalement elle va être
elle va y répondre dans un article
spécial aussi sur le sujet donc là de ce
côté là il ya un débat il ya des retours
il ya pas moins un petit pas d'accord
pour la médina ratings ne pas trop parce
qu'une fois j'ai voulu aller à une
conférence de cette part ne sait pas que
de 7
de cette figure du coup dames dinara qui
m'est fait un peu peur parce que j'avais
très simple et rationnellement
pédologiques peu paranoïaque
c'est un fait que j'avais pas trop lui
en bien après de dialoguer et par
rapport à tous tout le mouvement fait
qu'il a été tout ça donc l'homéopathie
les gros débat qui lie à ce que tu vois
les choses
du coup c'est un peu différent
enfin ça n'a pas trop de rapport avec ma
thèse même si je pense que les
défenseurs des médecines alternatives
met souvent en avant en avant le même
type de discours humaniste et s'appelle
bien aussi de démontrer que ces discours
sont pas forcément évident est parfait
après je me suis retrouvé à intervenir
sur le sujet des des médecines
alternatives et j'ai eu l'impression
dans des shows sauta monde banal donc
gers et d'interviews avec battre ce
cadre aura sûrement des choses banales
sur meetic sur le mont patiner ou sur
les médecines alternatives et en fait
les réactions elles ont été vraiment
étrange parce que je ne sais pas du tout
banal ce que je disais pas du tout
trivial et il ya plein de gens qui sont
pas d'accord notamment six nouveaux chez
les gens qui vont des tic sera vachement
l'étonné je ne sais pas trop
en france je veux dire sur quels points
particuliers ben ils ont discuté avec
elle sur déjà en france il ya beaucoup
de gens qui pensent vraiment que le
débat scientifique n'est pas clos
sûrement pas juste un truc de nos pattes
quoi champions qui croient que c'est pas
déjà pas de le débat n'est pas clos
pour le coup là si on adopte du cadre de
styggen gars c'est à dire que c'est
gagné
il reprend un article
car oui j'ai dit que j'attendais un peu
dur à lire mais on bosse idée qu après
plein plein plein décès d'études etc
et alors qu'on s'écarte de publication
n'a pas réussi à prouver que ça marchait
par avoir des données pour que ça marche
en du coup on peut conclure que ça
marche pas d'un moment on a tellement de
de données on attend donc d'absence de
données que peut-être en fait on nous
donnait en défaveur du fait qu'elle soit
gérée et ça c'est un truc qui est pas du
tout trivial et il ya plein de gens qui
pensent que celle inverse que tant qu'on
n'a pas de donné que ça marche mais il
ya plein de gens qui pensent que
l'absence de preuve n'est pas une preuve
de l'absence d'un gros c'est au
lancement et du coup pour le coude de
mon bâtiment c'est un peu ça qui est
utilisé pour dire bah oui on a aucune
timide que ça marche mais ça va pas dire
que ça marche pas et en fait donc si on
regarde du côté des pro ben c'est
exactement clair que ça sonne car je
pourrais te mettre j'ai pas été capables
d'aller dans le détail cet article le
premier s'est assez intuitive contre
s'il m'a tout ccc biais en faveur du
fait qu'on va trouver une infime
efficacité d'oncle un brin de cas
pourquoi on n'arrive pas avec 36 on n'y
arrive pas bon c'est comme un conte
sujet très très étudiée il ya d'énormes
intérêts à ceux qui une trouvaille
farine sachons les biais de publications
sait au moins que tout est fait de
placé en plus j'ai envie j'ai envie de
dire que je peux comprendre que par
exemple les antidépresseurs de tout on
est en vie absolument de trouver on
continue à faire plein appartient de
recherche déçu on ait envie que ça
marche quoi pour le bâtiment c'est que
ça fait presque rien donc enfin pourquoi
tant d'efforts du coup je comprends pas
du tout et voilà quand on sait qu'en
france c'est beaucoup utilisé j'ai voulu
faire une vidéo sur ma chaise noire je
n'étais pas très bien aussi parce que
pas je sais pas en fait il ya trop de
gens sont toute attaque et c'est
forcément difficile d'expliquer sans
paraître présenté en décembre et du coup
lorsque tu vois les choses évoluent
comme plus quand est ce qu'on peut faire
avance à rien ce que j'essaie pas là
c'est pas juste des patients des
médecins s'est aussi plaint de l'élite
intellectuelle entre deux mecs qui sont
en faveur de ça je ne sais pas tout le
monde par interdire aux gens d'en
acheter
mais personnellement je pense que
n'aurait pas vraiment c'est pas ça que
tu veux que je m'engage polémique
voilà qui venait de quitter mouillé
poser des questions sur vos comptes et
vaccins quelles sont les meilleures
façons de lutter contre ces nouveaux
[Musique]
marchés c'est non du tout je sais que la
plainte d'une jeune fille qui travaille
là dessus c'est marrant tu sors mon
laboratoire a organisé une journée sur
l'annexion des médicaments des mourides
et au times peut être que ça sera avant
la diffusion
mais en gros
ouais ça tourne autour de ces questions
pourquoi des gens se méfient n'y est pas
forcément s qui comprennent un peu
différent est ce que tu penses
est ce qu'on pourra le faire dans le
débat pour faire mieux
qu'est ce qu'on attend c'est bon d'être
les jours comment faire ben c'est
clairement ça sert à rien je pense de
s'énerver de faire des punchline de
faire le con reaganisme vraiment d'un
autre côté quand on essaye de rentrer
prisonniers des fois on n'est pas du
tout entendu n'est plus du coup c'est
difficile parce que soit on n'est pas
raisonnable et on peut toujours des fois
déclenché des polémiques sans faire
exprès soit on n'est pas trop on est
plus jeune fille là du coup moi créé des
polémiques qui peut-être bouger les
choses et en même temps faire des choses
caricatural
donc je sais pas facile non
je sais pas comment il faut avoir
confiance que les gens je crois pas que
ça ait crois pas qu un peu aussi bien
les gens à mieux réfléchir je vais pas
venir faire un cours personnes
en fait je sais pas s'échanger aucune
grande réponse aux problèmes du monde
est-ce que c'est cécile à la temps
j'avais pas répondu un truc
donc il faut être
il faut faire preuve d'humilité dans les
débats mais sachant ce que c'est mais
c'est même plus d'une ligne d'une hélice
mais il faut faire preuve d'humilité et
ça en être un peu à ceux qui savent quoi
et je m'inclus dedans quoi c'est pas
tout mais bon après c'est vrai que quand
on sait plus que plus trop de prendre de
décision il faut
ouais c'est un paradoxe ouais donc
encourager l'humilité wen et épices
tenir
c'est à dire que sur un sujet bon l
intuition problème en écosse ont fait
des recherches sur d'autres gens ont
pensé que probablement à mot ce qu'on
pense sais pas je sais pas moi je pense
que j'ai plein de chronos qui sont pas
trop rationnel qui se repose totalement
expertise toute personne ce qui m'a pas
dire qu'elle sera seulement voilà on
peut pas tout savoir il peut pas tout
faire seul et même temps quand on a une
position très forte et qu'on s'engueule
avec tout le monde sur internet il vaut
mieux réfléchir sinon vraiment en train
de faire quelque chose de productif
qu'on est sur la productivité de notre
moyen de communication de méthodes de
communication sur internet
c'est facile bah ouais ce que joseph
insistant un peu ce paradoxe dont je
pense que ma vidéo pour coup sûr mon
baptiste était pas c'est vraiment
difficile parce que quand il ya un sujet
qui nous paraît évident c'est compliqué
après deux de partir du coin de départ
de quelqu'un qui n'ont pas du tout cette
intention je crois est une vidéo après
avait parlé de ça un moment où ils
veulent appeler ça la malédiction du
savoir du fait que ouais c'est ça
n'oublie ce que c'est que de ne pas
savoir eh oui après je dis pas que ça me
plaise ou quoi etc c'est pour ça que
j'ai raté ma vidéo
travailler à 10 ans ou 16 fois de plus
d'un dans ok je pense qu'on peut aller
vers les dernières questions non encore
il va quel est le message clé que tu
aimerais semman jamais dit attendre du
rosier parce que le message qu'est que
tu est vrai que les éditeurs retiennent
de ses podcasts que c'est compliqué
allégations dans tous les offices du
coup et pour faire preuve de bien
bénisse et d'humilité par rapport à ses
propres compositions et ceux des autres
et je me donne ce qu'on se console le
conseil a marmonné si j'ai pas de
suspension a répliqué c'est pas facile
sinon est-ce que tu aurais tu dois faire
de recommandations de vidéos les
podcasts livres ou de personnes à suivre
du coup je recommande évidemment la
chaîne de thibault du coup dise
clairement je mène ce type boa bank
c'est ça même si je connais beaucoup qui
dans sa chaîne youtube et je me souviens
du moment où partage sur facebook et
lâche la route vraiment que je partage
sa vidéo en même temps c'est pas moi du
coup du coup j'ai cliqué mettant un peu
genre en fait c'était trop bien et trop
juste et l' armée c'est génial du coup
je les partage et à chaque fois je
partageais je regardais je te 30 16
janvier un parent jean melançon que
j'avais façon moyen d'enfants leur
expliquer ce que je faisais en philo de
pinède
donc c'est que sa chienne carrément et
apports en chinois
il s'est soudain au trou qu'est-ce que
si l'exercice
ah oui ah oui merci donc plus avec eux
qui le disent abonnez vous
à la chaîne youtube de nexus 6 une
chaîne dont la science fiction c'est
génial de relations sociales
c'est ça qui m'a fait perdre à pilot
enfin parce que quand vous voyez le truc
c'est d'avoir la science fiction et
grecque via la science fiction à la
philo je pense non mont jacob
mais c'est juste que comme la clusaz au
final tic et elle s'appuie beaucoup sur
sur des trucs demeure dans koh donc moi
je veux encore un peu là dedans ça m'a
parlé quoi ok donc tu conseilles office
of continentaux de regarder un peu de
science fiction pour essayer de voir ce
qui se passe aussi que vous l'ofit
analytique là encore plus penser qu'on
est bizarre bombe a su faire monter
quelque chose les 6 et 7 juin de
capitaine je peux rencontrer chez toi tu
connais pas et je le connais pas
personnellement j'ai connu le faussaire
des films récemment mais pas chez moi je
suis plus 606 bâti en tout cas beaucoup
y est pour cela que je parle d'un
philosophe et du coup j'ai apprécié
bâtiment même si on se sent beaucoup
voilà merci pour ce nouvel épisode de
probablement pensé à liker a commenté
faire tous les trucs classiques et à la
prochaine fois salut